sprinkles on bread so that's a famous
Australian snack called fairy bread I'm
going to have a little try that yeah go
for it you got Sweet Tooth yeah how is
it that's
[Laughter]
good why we there three
bit it's like what's that film starts
fooding food I was expecting not to like
it but I am a fan I'm not sure about
that can't be good for you though what
is this cucumber cream cheese yeah your
classic cucumber sandwich oh cucumber
sandwich okay I don't know about the
layering of that cuc I would go much
thinner on the Cucumber there that's too
much yeah the bread to cucumber ratio is
completely SCF I did I made that who's
responsible for
this absolutely dropped a B on this
one it'sing by the way okay okay you
think this is better
okay you know what you had to say
that